lors du jeu rappelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
alain chrétien
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
notre dame des landes a disparu disparue
de vos discours disparu de vos
engagements
disparue de vos priorités que sont
devenus les grandes déclarations
péremptoires de votre prédécesseur qui
s'engageait à faire évacuer la zone
à l'automne que sont devenus les grandes
déclarations du président sortant qui
s'engageait à faire respecter le
résultat du référendum ne nous parlez
pas du prétendu contentieux européen
prétexte qui n'existe pas et qui n'a
aucun fondement juridique sérieux
n'invoquait pas une indisponibilité des
forces de l'ordre qui serait occupé à
surveiller des marchés de noël la vérité
monsieur le premier ministre c'est que
vous êtes paralysé vous êtes dans une
impasse politique
écartelé entre madame royal tu ne veux
pas cet aéroport et les injonctions de
monsieur ayrault qui lui même premier
ministre a été incapable de faire sortir
ce dossier de terre une fois de plus
monsieur pour les ministes dans ce
mandat la parole de l'état sera
ridiculisé par ce reniement
supplémentaires alors monsieur le
premier ministre si vous voulez que
cette fan quinquennat soit utile et bien
respecter vos engagements
prenez ce dossier en main et régler le
plutôt que de le laisser à vos
successeurs
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre bernard cazeneuve
monsieur le député chrétien très très
franchement sur des sujets d'une telle
importance d'une telle complexité aussi
est ce que nous pourrions essayer plutôt
que de nous faire des procès d'intention
plutôt que d'être dans la polémique
d'examiner les questions et d'y apporter
les réponses les plus pertinentes
ce sujet je le connais bien j'ai été
ministre de l'intérieur et le précédent
prémices m'avait demandé de préparer
l'évacuation que la zad de notre dame
des landes et j'ai sur cette question
une vision extrêmement clair que je vais
exprimer devant la représentation
nationale
nous sommes dans un état de droit et
depuis maintenant près de 14 ans l'état
a pris en liaison avec les collectivités
locales
l'ensemble des dispositions qui devaient
être prises pour permettre la
réalisation de cette grande
infrastructure parce que nous sommes
dans un état de droit
des recours sont intervenus 169 très
exactement au terme desquels raison a
toujours été donnée à l'état dont il a
été reconnu qu'à chaque étape de la
procédure il avait respecter
rigoureusement le droit en vigueur
la commission européenne a fait un
certain nombre de remarques concernant
ce projet dans le cadre d'une démarche
précontentieuse les collectivités
locales ont décidé d'intégrer dans le
scot
les remarques de la commission
européenne de telle sorte à le rendre
conforme à ses préconisations et le scot
sera examinée et sans doute voté le 19
décembre prochain et nous serons à ce
moment là dans une situation qui nous
permettra de vérifier que l'intégration
dans le scot de mesures nouvelles
correspond à ce que la commission
attendait et que nous sommes sortis du
précontentieux ensuite il ya bien
entendu sur cette question une position
claire à voir le sujet n'est pas
monsieur chrétien de savoir s'il faut ou
non
évacué la za de notre dame des landes
bien entendu qu'il faut le faire il faut
le faire pour des raisons qui tiennent
au fait que dans un état de droit le
droit doit être respecté que nul ne peut
par la violence se poser à l'expression
de la souveraineté des élus lorsqu'ils
respectent le droit ni aux décisions
qu'ils prennent
mais la question est de savoir comment
via le faire
parce que sur un sujet de ce type comme
sur la question de calais il ne s'agit
pas d'être comme vous l'avez été dans
les incantations il faut être dans la
méthode il faut être dans l'efficacité
et il faut être sûr que l'opération
qu'on conduit sera une opération qui se
déroulera sans violence qui se déroulera
avec une véritable réussite et la
possibilité pour cette infrastructure de
se faire c'est la raison pour laquelle
compte tenu de ce qu'est le niveau de
mobilisation des forces vous pouvez
l'ignorer mais moi je ne peux pas
l'ignorer parce qu'il menace terroriste
extrêmement importante à licques à
laquelle l'état doit faire face j'ai
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
dans la continuité de bien vouloir selon
les étapes à franchir
déterminer les conditions qu'il ya une
opération pragmatique efficace et qui
permettent de faire en sorte que cet
aéroport puisse se faire mais